Honus dakarai mocks Spellman I'm the
global head of strategy and I'm freaking
to answer your question about technology
and how it can help with employment
opportunities I think we're on the cusp
of a major new wave of technology if you
look at things like job computing the
whole question about superfast broadband
issues around sort of mobiles and
sensors and it's not the technologies
themselves are important but it's what
they the opportunities that they sort of
represent and we've all know that for
example through our mobile telephones
the new and different applications that
we'll be able to access but you see
particularly this massive increase in
computer power the fantastic
opportunities to present and that's true
in the business of business space so for
example and you look at the growth in
machine-to-machine their communications
the ability to do remote diagnostics but
also critically I think in terms of the
digital enablement of people and whether
that young people here today are very
good with apparent pcs and Internet but
also increasingly with aging populations
particularly the West the importance of
being able to make them more digitally
literate enables them to be able to work
longer and be able to have I think more
productive life so for me technology is
just a fundamentally neighbor he creates
great opportunities for us and again you
just have to look at everything from
things like rural banking where we no
longer need I'm actually banks in the
physical locations but the chickens are
all transactions through the internet
these are just huge new opportunities
which will create massive job
opportunities I think both in the west
where a lot of the technologies are
developed but also critically in
emerging markets where these new
technologies will create new business
models so I'm very bullish and
optimistic about technology I hope that
gives you a little bit more confidence
that technology can be your friend and
not necessarily your enemy and above all
thanks very much for listening